[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk with the king
now it's 2019 our hame is in full swing
PBC is about the due date thing it's a
19th first big fight of the year yes
Pacquiao Manny pacman Pacquiao vs.
Adrian the problem Brona see I had a lot
of frustration and anxiety trying to
decipher this fight because um whatever
you do get a chance to see like when
they're training in all access and any
phone calls that I do get a chance to
make reaching out to individuals because
you know I have about New Jack fighting
on that card and I'm good friends with
his trainers and stuff like that so my
peek in
I get a different type of peek in and
see what these guys are really ready for
you know saying so the inside he got
into this fight is you have youth versus
experience and that's another way of
saying old do you know Manny Pacquiao is
a great fighter powerful pound at one
point but you can't really say pound for
pound you can only say he is powerful
pound when Floyd stepped away from the
game because Floyd is and will be the
dominant force in this generation Manny
Pacquiao will always be part to being
that they fought and what happened we
saw the result of this fight if anyone
wants to believe this guy shoulder was
hurt no shoulder was not hurt what
happens with Pacquiao is um when you
count to punch him properly when he's
trying to attack and he gets counter
punch properly he gets a little
standoffish she's lesson entitled
to feel like he can he can get in there
really fight so he kind of steps back
and takes his foot off the gas and tries
to figure it out what the thing is with
Mayweather is you know he's like a
Rubik's Cube not gonna figure a mouse or
the whole fight you're just looking like
the same everybody has the same face now
going into this fight elephant in the
room bro I don't know try all the
understand that elephant in the room is
you guys that felt that you know Manny
Pacquiao if his shoulder was better he
would beat me with him all right and you
know a lot of you guys see Adrien Broner
as you know the main weather clone he
was supposedly to step up right
Mayweather 2.0 not even close um but the
thing is what you would see with Adrien
Broner which I'll perceive to see is
that he's a more aggressive with their
Philly crab shell style so he uses the
shoulder roll he comes in he gives sharp
punches and he is more adapt to if he
has a Pacquiao in trouble
he's more adept to push the limit and
try to get him out of there okay so now
that we understand we have we have youth
versus experience Manny Pacquiao's last
couple of fights if y'all didn't notice
he has lost a step he attacks straight
ahead normally he would have beat Jeff
long he would knock Jeff on out had
there been Pacquiao in his prime at 28
years old he is 20 years past his prime
let that wash over you so a lot of you
guys I remember him when he fought
certain guys like Ricky Hatton and he
fought Cotto and death destr Oscar De La
Hoya fighters you know seeing him um
he's not that guy he can still be a
violent puncher but the pop isn't there
you know he hasn't knocked the guy out
in a very long time don't say Matty stay
misty you say quit I told you guys I'm
teasing we'll quit all right
Adrien Broner
um he's untapped potential you know
every big fight he's supposed to step up
and fight and he never really realizes
his potential going into the fight he
always comes up a little bit short right
and you know if only Adrian lets his
hands go that has always been a story
that will always continue to be the
story
Adrian grown will not throw punches and
bunches like people want him to do he is
not that stand off on the jab and
working work type he do like he is a
potshot or he was a plotter he is uh
he's a trap set he you see a set of trap
if you fall for the trap when he catches
you with a punch he tries to get you out
of there but if not he's content to try
to work all night alright so these two
guys it's hard to say basically what
you're gonna get
I mean I really truly believe Pacquiao
is gonna come out for the first five to
six rounds and sweet five or six rounds
I believe that he's going to go out
there and he's going to work hard punch
Adrian gets punched in the mouth he's
going to show you gonna stand back if
you've noticed anything about aging
umbrella fights
the man has a chin don't ever take
anything away from him he can boxing he
has a chin alright so he takes a shot he
keeps going he pushes forward he always
closes the show strong if Adrian bowler
can fight the twelfth round like every
other round like the first round
probably would not have ever had a loss
but he doesn't fight that way so what we
gonna have is Manny Pacquiao take the
first five to six rounds and Adrien
Broner Brona
come on and take the last six rounds
would it be a 12 round even fight no
because you know you know the judges
will be looking for this I'm looking for
that and maybe they might give one
around him one around there I fully
believe that uh Adrien Broner is going
to try his hardest
I believe
you probably see the best Adrien Broner
you can get and both of these guys have
money issues so both of these guys are
highly motivated they both came in at
146 for Pacquiao and 146 and a half for
Bruner that means he's taking the fight
seriously he's not a weight he didn't
over train he looked he didn't look
dried out
Kevin Cunningham Adrien Broner his lead
trainer as a hatter one point he looks
very good he looks very sharp in
training Manny Pacquiao brought back
Freddie Roach in for this fight and I
believe he brought Freddie Roach in
because he understands exactly what type
of power and person Adrien Broner is so
I believe both of these guys are taking
it seriously I believe financially they
need this fight but I leave I believe
going forward because they're both
chasing their mayweather fight they're
now looking at these other champions out
there these two guys understand that
they have built up a situation a
storyline that Mayweather can come in
and pick the winner of this fight
because they pack y'all wins he can say
well Pacquiao beat a little broke and I
got to come out of retirement and hand
this hand let's do you know he said his
shoulder was hurt last time I don't want
no excuses boom bang and you get that
funny um Adrien Broner
if he knocks out Pacquiao he can be like
I did it better than you big bro you
understand so we have highly motivated
individuals that look for the win they
both pretty much want the knockout they
do because that will force me whether
it's hand
um last night let's not get it twisted
this is all about the next fight this is
all about that Bret but tonight is a
night for champions this is uh present
past champions and could be a future
champion but I do beseech see it going
as split-decision 12 rounds with Manny
Pacquiao coming on top in gym brewing
again pissed off and saying that he did
enough
to win but in reality if he came out a
little bit fast in the beginning in the
early rounds he could have definitely
got the win um maybe there's a knock
down somewhere in between here it's
possible with these two individuals but
do I see it no but I say I highly
entertaining fight I see when it gets to
the eighth and ninth rounds you see a
lot of back-and-forth you see a lot of
pushing but Manny is at the point in his
career where he gets cut up some there's
a lot of blood there so you you might
get a stoppage um if there is a stoppage
then you know as Adrien Broner that got
to stoppage because I don't believe
Pacquiao has the gumption or enough
punching power or volume of punches to
knock out Adrien Broner get him in
trouble maybe knock him out no so that's
my prediction 2019 starting off with a
bang it's great to be back baby
combat talk with the king see y'all soon
we got that Mikey Garcia Earl Spence and
those are two brothers in their prime
[Applause]
[Music]